so the other day I give a thousand
dollar tip at the restaurant and I post
the receipt with a story behind it and
people some of them lost their minds I
want to tell you today why when you go
out there and do acts of kindness why
you ought to share it publicly and I
know many say don't do it I'm telling
you do it my argument is coming here
shortly if you get value from this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so I don't know how close to
your following on what's going on with
art as an alternative investment but a
lot of major companies like Goldman
Sachs Pimco they're starting to talk to
their clients about alternative
investment matter of fact this last year
I was at Art basil and guess who was
there Goldman Sachs I had a dinner with
them and it was all around people that
are investing millions of dollars into
art as an alternative investment here's
some stats 2022 was the biggest auction
year ever highest total from Victory
auction houses nearly 18 billion dollars
so now you may say Pat that's great I
can't afford to buy five million piece
of art or an 800 000 piece art I don't
have that kind of money you sometimes
talk about baseball cards you bought
four million dollars I don't have that
kind of money I understand the same way
they created mutual funds a company
called Masterworks allows you to buy
into art by Andy Warhol Pablo Picasso
whoever may be Banksy but you buy shares
of that art so you'll say here's a
million dollar piece I own a share of
this art and then while they sell it you
make the return on that piece of art so
today with what's going on with
inflation what's going on with the
economy what's going on with the stock
market people are a little bit concerned
one of the asset classes people are
looking at is alternative Investments
specifically in art and if you want to
participate in this I highly recommend
you look into Masterworks everything
they do is buy the books SEC you you
have to do your own due diligence while
you go through but if it is something
you want to participate in click on the
link below if you get involved with them
it's By Invitation Only they have 600
000 people already that are working with
Masterworks and if you want to diversify
your portfolio I highly recommend you
consider Masterworks my wife is born on
Valentine's Day February 14 so we're
going out there in Miami we go to this
restaurant called Joe stone crab we go
grab a seat this lady comes up her name
is Kira and she's giving us incredible
service and while we're eating I love
learning about a restaurant so tell me a
story about this place I've been here
before but I don't really know the
history well see that picture that's the
family but here that's Joe this is how
this place got started in 1913 just less
than 20 years after Miami got started in
1896. this place was nothing Miami was
nothing people only came here for this
and he started this and it's been around
for four generations and it's the number
one restaurant in America for grossing
top-line Revenue I'm like you got to be
kidding me pre-pandemic number one
restaurant ingross Revenue only one
place like wow that's intense and I'm
looking around my wife and I I'm like
babe how many people think work here I
don't know let me ask here Akira comes
back hey Kira how many people work here
well we have this many waiters and
waitresses I'm number 24 out of whatever
89 I think she said we have nearly you
ready 400 employees
One Restaurant nearly 400 employees she
walks so I'm like oh my God 400
employees every Arnold Palmer refill she
brought it I never asked for it my wife
lemon lime everything we ordered she was
Flawless on the way she handled us and
then at the end we got a surprise came
and desert all this other stuff and then
I noticed everybody that was coming in
that would go to this lady with their uh
whatever they're bringing to the
customers and this lady had to look at
there's a receipt and Vermont like what
did they do in their stuff I don't know
what they're doing over there so secure
is just out of curiosity why do all
those waiters and waitresses why do you
guys all stand in line there and you
talk to that lady says well I've been
here for 20 years and boom this is what
she said today is actually my 20 year
anniversary I'm like oh wow so what do
you talk to that lady for she says we
take our receipt and she checks portions
portions yes
she checks portions yeah like did I put
too much salad did I put too much crabs
did I put too much this I said damn you
know portions why would they do this
interesting so somebody if you have a
friend coming and they don't put more
crab legs I said is that why they do
that's exactly why they do it how long
they've been doing it for they've been
doing it for 20 years as long because
I've been here what an incredible system
so I said so I noticed every food that
came to us you brought it to us yes here
we bring it to you and we're held
accountable I said so if I tip you
there's a tip go to you does a tip go to
everybody shares it together she said no
it goes to me because I'm held
responsible to bring in the food too
great system I said so tell me how do
you like working here are you kidding me
I'm so grateful I'm so happy this
company's changed my life I've been here
for 20 years today's my 20 years you
know that I'm like wow she got emotional
listening to her story and by the way
you know how this lady was super humble
like the tap of a person you want as a
mother as a sister as a friend man like
emotionally so likable I'm like babe
she says I know what you're gonna do I
said I'm gonna do it babe do your thing
great I'm going to give her a thousand
dollar tip so I give her a thousand
twenty dollar tip so the receipt was
like 400 bucks and getting a thousand
twenty dollars tip twenty dollars to
represent 20 or she's been there
thousand dollars and I give it to her
and she says what's this what are you
doing no you you what do you do what is
you're kidding me so the reaction was so
innocent so awesome so grateful exact
reaction you would be hoping to get I
got okay and I said I'm gonna post this
on Instagram Facebook LinkedIn give her
love and encourage everybody to go there
and take care of her when they go to
this place I post it comments awesome
pad your top G you're great you're this
your dad all these affirm me positive
comments now I know what comments are
coming though and you know I do it
intentionally anyways because I know
what they're going to be saying and what
they don't realize is I intentionally
posted it because I know pisses a lot of
people off let me read some of the
comments here's what some people said
that's all good but you're supposed to
do these Good Deeds things out of the
goodness of your heart not to post on
social media and Brad set a better
example okay great so listen logically
you would see that if you gone to church
or you're raised in a Christian family
or any kind of denomination you'd say
he's right you shouldn't do this perfect
let me give you my argument social media
do you see things that people pick up
that are bad habits things they
shouldn't be doing how do you fight that
so let me get the straight so the bad
habits promoted as much as you want but
listen all the good people do don't
advertise it God forbid you're going to
be judged for it how do you fight
negative habits and negative behavior by
showing good gestures Mr Beast every
time he goes and changes someone's life
and gives ten thousand dollars fifty
thousand dollars here's the car here's
the house he's got thousands of other
YouTubers now are doing the same thing
to be like Mr Beast are we teaching
giving that's a good thing because for
the most part everything's promoting
what taking taking these guys are
teaching giving and we should say hey Mr
Beast stop giving away money to people
you're not doing a good deed stay quiet
while you're doing this I say keep
giving because God knows the way Mr
Beast is going in the next 10 20 years
he's going to be giving away billions of
dollars and you ain't paying taxes for
that he's choosing to give that away
keep giving Mr Beast let me read the
next comment to you I can't even afford
a 400 meal let alone a thousand dollar
tip so how do you think it feels to
millions of Americans out there at these
times this is a boast and a lot of you
will be impressed yeah okay there was a
time I couldn't afford to have a
lemonade or a Coke but I dreamed of one
day possibly doing more there was a time
I went to a Christmas party with my
sister and my father sitting there and
her husband and they didn't go to a
honeymoon and I didn't have a dollar to
give a gift to neither one of them and I
saw other people doing it and it
inspired me I didn't about it I
said I'd love to one day do it you ought
to start thinking bigger so you can
contribute to your own family and the
people around you shouldn't say I can't
believe you're doing this and I can't
ever do it you should say wow if he did
it I can as well that's an identity flaw
on you day you gotta check not me what
feels better leaving a thousand dollars
or tip or telling people about it both
I'm very comfortable with it I think you
ought to give a thousand dollar tip and
if you can get a chance to challenge and
Inspire other people to do so do it but
in this situation how do you think hero
feels how do you think she feels being
recognized what do you think she got
this kind of recognition getting
millions of views you think she's happy
she got the love you think she's happy
she's being recognized for going above
and beyond you think she's going to go
tell that story and say you know what
happened today today 20 year anniversary
I got this do you think that message of
encouraging people to not quit not give
up stay somewhere be a leader make it
work be grateful have the right attitude
do you think that is an example more
people need to emulate I've been in
business for a long time I tell you not
a lot of people have that attitude
positivity grateful let me give my best
let me do good even when some of these
things are not going good I'm keeping my
chin up I'm still doing my job I'm being
Dependable reliable accountable yes I
think a lot of people ought to emulate
Kiara's habits and the story needs to be
told this next one here really messes
with a lot of people's minds and I had a
hard time with this one 15 years ago 10
years ago but you're going to see what
angle I'm going to take with this here's
what one person said pbd is worth
approximately 200 billion dollars it's
like me tipping a dollar two cents we're
not impressed by you big fella okay let
me explain this to you my wife and I are
in Monaco we're sitting down okay we had
sold the company this is the biggest
amount of money that came into our
accounts and the first time you look at
it like wow look at this I said let me
explain to you what's going to happen
next you're about to be a taxi so what I
mean I'm about to be attacked this
here's what's going to happen if all of
a sudden people realize how much money
you have all the money you give them
they're always going to say you're so
greedy that's all you gave us that's all
you gave us that's all you gave us
people who don't want to work for their
money no matter how much you ever give
them it's never enough it's the
entitlement attitude right Steve Jobs
and apple never gave away to charity why
not interesting right you think about it
Kirk accordion owner of MGM catalog
movies all of that casino died at one
point it was worth nine billion dollars
he died at 98 years old one of the most
successful entrepreneurs of all time
incredible story what this guy did right
and he gave all this money to Armenia at
one point like around a billion dollars
a lot of money you know what they said
that's all you get that's not enough if
you read this book you know what it said
he never wanted to help that Community
out even though he's Armenian he didn't
he's like I'm done I don't want to help
out anymore because he was discreet he
says I'm going to do it in a completely
different way he made a movie because he
could control it he didn't give away to
charity anymore so this is the part that
I want everybody who was like well
that's why I don't want to do it because
no matter what I do you know there's
going to be people that are not grateful
it doesn't matter that's the risk you
take you don't give hoping that
everybody likes it you don't do certain
things hoping everybody supports it this
is one of many stories of what we do you
don't go advertising every single one of
them but I do believe you if you do a
good service or a good deed out there
share it with others don't feel guilty
about it we need more stories the
question and the debate this led to is
the following debate which by the way
some of you guys are going to love this
year if Jesus was around today and their
social media say he's around today you
think he's on social media I don't think
he'd ever be on social media really
really
so you think he would only spend time at
churches you think he would only be
places because it's only other
Christians that's where he would be no I
think you'd be on social media telling
his story matter of fact I'm willing to
tell you not enough Christians are on
social media the churches that are
growing they're leveraging social media
a lot of these guys that are trying to
groom kids and the negative mindset
they're on social media and you don't
want to match that with goodness I don't
know about that I think that's a
outdated philosophy that needs to be
challenged today and I think people like
Mr Beast and others are doing a great
job giving and they're inspiring kids
which is very important to be
comfortable to give in a society like
this so this whole thing was to give a
shout out to Kiera and to encourage
others to tell stories of people who
give 20 years of their life and service
to a company and do it in a grateful
positive attitude Kiera this whole thing
was for you I got a lot of respect for
you so I'm reading a book right now that
I'm fascinated by which I've recommended
on my Instagram phenomenal book is about
service I did a video years ago on the
concept of customer service versus
customer experience my whole experience
at Joe stonecrap was an experience not
just because of customer service if
you've never seen this video I highly
highly recommend you watching this video
to create memorable moments for the
people you're serving if you've never
seen this click here to watch it take
everybody bye bye
foreign
[Music]